unemployment claimants who have bank of
america cards say they're still having
trouble today
accessing their weekly payments now
yesterday deter tweeted there was an
issue with the system but it was fixed
joe mohler spoke to some who are still
having issues
i tried to pull money off of the
unemployment card
and it said that i my card was having
technical difficulties
garen bavino says she has been trying to
access her unemployment benefits since
tuesday with her bank of america
unemployment card
it's really frustrating and yesterday
there was lines
everywhere so everyone was just wasting
time on something they couldn't pull
it is an issue a number of claimants
have been having tuesday deters said
this was resolved in a tweet but some
say it happened again wednesday
some are forced to go to another bank i
guess you can pull from your own bank
right now but you're going to be charged
extra
we reached out to dieter again they tell
us the issue that happened was resolved
and people should call the number on the
back of their card
a representative from bank of america
told me the unemployment cards were
operating as usual
they also said people should call the
number on the back why bevino and others
are having problems is not known
and it's the same old story every time
and it seems like it's a finger pointing
game
amber hansen runs a popular unemployment
assistance facebook page
she says on the page they have noticed
issues with the bank of america cards
for months
we have now this issue which is where
like the money's being held or it gets
released and then they go to the bank
and they can't get the money
and and then you know there's this
finger pointing back and forth of
who's doing what vino says she tried
calling the number on the back of the
card but she said now she has an issue
that she is only able to get twenty
dollars
at a time reporting in las vegas joe
mohler eight news now